Da da,
and we're live and you have come
bringing the future.
This is what we've all hoped for.
We had all heard about this when we were
kids.
Do,
they're going to sell.
We'd like cigarettes in a carton.
It'll going to be pre rolled and you're
going to be buying it just like you buy
a Marlboro and you've,
you've come bringing this.
This is real sure.
Yeah.
It's a real thing though.
Where'd you get those?
Um,
I got them into the Seattle when we just
played there.
The company brought us a whole gift bag
and it hasn't worked with transport,
with things like that.
Well,
I guess if I told you,
screw up our transport.
Definitely I'm not a traveler with.
I'm acquire when you get there kind of a
guy.
Sure.
I think it's usually the best move.
It's just,
it is the best move.
But uh,
do they even bother checking people in
the Seattle airport anymore?
You know,
we're on a bus.
It's totally different.
Yeah,
of course.
So except if you go to Texas,
I would never,
I would never take it on a plane.
No,
not a good move.
Not a good move,
but when they arrested Willie Nelson in
Texas and like,
wow,
that's how much.
They don't make exceptions.
Yeah.
That was weird.
That was stupid.
It's ridiculous.
I mean,
it hurts my feelings.
It's like,
really,
this is what you're doing.
You're trying to solve crime arrests in.
What does he eat now?
Will.
He's got to be close to 80.
I mean,
he's got to be in the top 10 of people
who have done more for the state of
Texas than anyone.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
come on now.
He died.
He's undeniably awesome.
I mean,
enough.
I was a great guy.
Yeah.
Like,
why would you want to arrest that guy?
That's,
you know,
can you imagine willie?
He was probably like really serious and
sad.
It's sad.
It's someone must've felt kind of
embarrassed.
I bet.
Yeah.
And we were talking today because today
this is good.
This is a historic day for music because
of Prince.
I mean,
this is,
um,
it's very strange when a guy that's that
powerful,
especially when I was a kid during my
teen years.
I mean,
there was,
when he was,
you know,
really emerging and that's when people
were really finding out about him.
I remember thinking like,
wow,
this guy is so interesting.
It's such a combination of different
things like that.
He was,
there was no one that was like him
before.
I mean David Bowie was sort of
androgynous before,
but he took it into a different new
place and it was mysterious and had some
with David Bowie.
For me,
it always felt more like theater with
prince.
It felt more like prince,
you know,
that's really him,
you know?
Yeah.
Purple Rain and then did the movie
because he just started that way,
but we kind of transformed into that
androgyny.
Prince was like that to begin with.
Right?
Yeah.
I remember the first time pat and I
played the first avenue in Minneapolis.
That's where they shot,
I think some parts from maybe the live.
Is that right?
The live segments from,
from that movie.
And uh,
that was the big thing,
you know?
Yeah.
Just to be as well.
He kind of owned Minneapolis,
right?
He put Minneapolis on the map and he
stayed there.
Yeah,
and you thought of many.
I like thought of Prince.
You thought of Minneapolis.
That was part of the thing is that he
was,
as this wizard that lived in this frozen
land and produced all this crazy music,
they never would have arrested prints
for we'd know in Minneapolis.
No.
Now he gets a hall pass.
Yeah,
he was the man in Minneapolis.
I mean every he was,
he's a god there.
I wonder what it was that got them,
you know,
it's 57 years old.
I mean,
he's a thin guy.
Looks like he's healthy.
He looked very healthy.
He looked like he could have been
mistaken for Ferrell.
I mean,
he was like,
yeah,
those two guys are like ageless,
you know,
and he did a show just a couple of
nights ago.
Yeah,
he was on tour.
Um,
I dunno,
it's just so wild.
Well,
it's so hard when something like that
happens,
you can only speculate.
You don't.
No one really knows until you hear.
It's just,
it just reinforces this idea that we're
so fragile.
This all could go away.
And yeah,
like,
like I said,
it's like it doesn't matter how much
money you have can have the best doctors
in the world and it's just,
you have to be thankful for what you
have got to be a good human because it
can just all go away so quickly and
eventually it's all going to go away for
all of us.
Yeah,
very soon.
One hundred percent.
Life is very short.
It's 100 percent not going to last.
Hondo says nobody gets out alive.
Right?
No one instill.
It's a people run through life
accumulating shit.
Yeah.
And,
and missing missing opportunities to
just take it all in and enjoy it.
And when a guy like prince,
one of the undeniable things that he
left was a,
I mean,
you will always have his catalog of work
to make people happy.
Like he left a,
an undeniable impact on people.
You know,
to this day,
uh,
I will pull out,
I wanna be your lover because that was
the first big hit.
And like that still to this day,
a fucking bad ass song.
Absolutely.
You know what,
what really kills me though is when you
get an artist who people just weren't
ready for and they're only,
they're only shown love after they die.
Do you know what I mean?
That kind of kills me.
That's going to be the case here.
You know,
for sure he's going to get when he was
always showing love,
but he'll be showing a lot more love.
People appreciate them now that they
know it's ended.
What do,
I mean?
That's what happened to Michael Jackson.
Michael Jackson before he died,
people weren't nearly as interested in
him because he was like,
once he died,
like once he died,
then his catalog went through the roof
and everybody wanted to buy the old
stuff up and all the prince stuff is
like charting now.
You know,
man,
I was thinking about Bill Hicks the
other day and how he died at his mom's
and Arkansas.
He will.
He knew it was going down for awhile.
He had pancreatic cancer and it was.
It's a particularly brutal kind of
cancer apparently,
especially in the nineties when bill
died of it and he knew and just went to
his mom's place to die,
but just thinking about that,
like you just sort of never made it,
made it.
He know what I mean.
Yeah.
And then he dies and then all of a
sudden everybody says,
oh,
he was the best.
He was one of the best comics all the
time.
You know,
he was certainly one of the most
influential,
no doubt about it.
He,
he changed so many people's perception
of what comedy could be.
He like opened up a whole new way.
He's like,
well,
comedy could do that too.
And everybody was like,
Ooh,
nobody did that before,
you know,
he had a,
like a consciousness to his comedy or
like an elevation sorta thing to his
comedy where he's trying to change your
thought process along with make you
laugh.
Yeah,
very different thing.
It's hard.
It's hard to get to that place.
That's the place you always want to get
to.
Some people are just born there,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like we're talking about prince,
he was prince when he started,
he had the third eye when he started.
You know what I mean?
I think it takes some people some time
on stage to figure themselves out.
It takes a few years of like making
mistakes,
listening to too many people.
Yeah,
yeah.
You could definitely get off on bad pass
and you've got to recorrect come back.
You have to.
I mean there's a learning process to
everything.
That's what's so difficult with cell
phones nowadays.
It's like you can't learn in private,
you know,
you used to be able to go on stage and
like practice kind of in front of
people,
which is the best practice,
you know,
but now everything's filmed.
Even your shit that you're trying to
work out,
you can't just be so free.
Do you know what I mean?
Big with big deal with standup.
That's a big deal with standup because
the bits,
if you hear them and then you hear the
finished product,
it will.
If you hear the like the starting,
like you should ideally he'll hear it
for the first time in full form and
completed for him,
but a lot of people along the way,
what people enjoy that process,
they'll like coming to the comedy store
and watching people stumble through an
idea that they're not exactly sure.
And then they'll see that bit,
maybe six months later on a television
specialist.
I'm sure he figured it out.
But um,
yeah,
it's.
But he could also choose as a fan to not
seek that stuff out.
I think people do.
Yeah.
You know,
it,
it stops me from wanting to play songs.
I don't really know.
Wow.
Absolutely.
Because you're worried that like a video
of it getting out there,
being kind of in the halfway hacking my
way down new song,
you know,
I wouldn't do it.
Fuck.
Absolutely.
Well if you think it's really stifled,
stifled some modern performing.
Have you seen some of those things that
Chappelle's done and um,
I'm Hannibal burress has done.
They take these bags and you put your
cell phone in and we to go in and it's
sealed.
And when you're in the room,
you literally can open the bag and then
if you leave the room somehow there's
some sensor and allows you to open the
bag.
It seems like a ridiculous idea.
But the more I about it,
it seems like
it's the kind of thing that people may
fight.
But then thank you for afterwards.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
For the experience themselves,
you're like,
Holy Shit,
I haven't really paid attention anything
for an hour and a half,
two hours,
uh,
for years.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Well,
if you go to a concert now,
all you see is phones up and people
watching the concert through phones.
Yeah.
I mean you see this,
you see people doing this all the time.
You're like,
you'll,
you'll see a sea of cell phones at these
arenas.
And it's weird.
They used to reach out and try to touch
me.
Now they either reach out to,
to,
to take a picture.
Did you notice a shift or it's slowly,
like almost like people were infected by
phones,
like the tin man.
I mean,
when we started,
I was a flip phone generation.
I know those are two problematic,
so hard.
Take a picture with some people were
into it,
but most people left them in their
pockets.
Yeah.
No,
because the picture's sucked.
I mean,
it's not something you want to brag
about now.
Everybody's like the best photographer
ever with the iphone.
Yeah.
They're so good now and they're getting
better all the time and they're also
putting those little lenses on them.
They're making them even better.
They slide a little lens over the top of
it.
You see a lot of that,
but people aren't experiencing it in a
pure way.
You know you're not going to it and just
sitting there and taking in the show.
Instead you're going into it and you're
aware that you were recording it and you
want to make sure you get it in frame
and you make sure you've got a good part
that's going to look good on your
facebook or wherever the fuck you're
going to put it.
You missing your.
You're not giving into the experience of
the music or the show or whatever.
You're going to 100 percent.
Life is not as good with cell phones.
I think,
but I have it in my hand all day long.
I don't.
I wouldn't say that life is not as good.
It's more challenging because it doesn't
prevent you from putting it away,
but it makes it very addictive.
It's very hard to put it away,
but you could.
I think it's the kind of I think is the
kind of thing where like your life would
be better if you didn't have it.
You would be able to experience life
more.
You'd paid more attention to your kids
and you'd have more real,
true love.
You know,
you wouldn't be taking fucking selfies
to post.
You'd actually be hugging them
genuinely.
Do you know what I mean?
I think a can't do both.
I don't think so.
I've not met that person.
I don't know man.
I love the data though.
I love all the information.
I love the light.
Come on to it.
Yeah.
Well it's interesting.
I mean there's always something new.
There's always some new story that's out
there.
Some new revelation,
scientific invention experiment that was
done that some.
There's some new shit always.
Constantly.
It's like the amount of data that we're
getting now is,
but is it making us.
Hasn't made us better.
Do you think you would question.
You think you're happier since you've
had google in your pocket?
Twenty four slash seven.
I'm happy if someone starts talking shit
and I know they're wrong.
Whip out my phone.
Wrong son.
Just Google.
That's nice.
You're the Google data [inaudible] you
would have left that party.
Like,
fuck,
I got to
learn more about something.
You know what I mean?
Maybe I would have left that fully.
Shit.
I know he's full of Shit.
I just wish I had my phone.
Yeah.
Oh well wait.
Leave parties thinking people are full
of Shit.
That's weird.
No,
I'm in la somewhere.
If I didn't have a phone.
Yeah.
If you,
if you leave a party in La and you don't
think someone was full of Shit,
you're in the wrong party.
There's definitely a lot of that out
here.
Or maybe you're just where you need to
be.
I can't say I really go to parties.
Um,
I might've been a dozen parties out here
in my entire life.
Yeah.
Probably worked,
nobody inviting.
You just go busy working nights.
First of all,
I don't have a lot of friends that put
on parties.
That's not normal.
I made me be like a pool party or
something like that.
You go over a buddy's house,
your barbecue,
but that,
you know,
like a party party.
I've been to a few of those like
Hollywood parties where you're walking
around and go,
oh,
there's drew barrymore.
How fucking weird.
And you go into another room.
This Ben Stiller,
I'll fucking weird.
And you feel totally out of place and
you got to get out of there as quick as
you can.
I've been to a couple of those but never
sought them out.
They always seemed odd.
Yeah.
I don't love him so much.
We,
uh,
we stay at the um,
the chateau,
of course you do.
It's bad.
It has to be.
I mean that's the spot and Hollywood,
that's the authentic spot.
It's so cliche,
but I mean,
I've just been there.
Yeah.
Sleeping in the bed where,
you know,
Belushi died,
just like raging,
you know what I mean?
Learning nothing from his mistakes.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I've woken up at that in that,
in that a place like blood on the walls,
just like what happened?
Have we learned nothing from this guy's
dead.
Do you think that places like that
contain memory is that there's a real
thought and we've brought it up before
comics at the comedy store because the
comedy store used to be Ciro's
nightclub.
It was owned by Bugsy Siegel,
the mobster,
and so there's murders that were there.
There's weed,
there's definitely murdered.
It was a murder that was there just a
year ago.
Somebody got murdered on the front patio
at the comedy store were like the rich
history of weirdness and of comedy.
It seems to be in the walls.
Do you feel like that about the Chateau
Marmont because if you go to that place,
I mean,
is there one place more synonymous with
Hollywood debacle than that place?
I mean,
not only that might be the hotel in
Hollywood where you think of like Johnny
Depp's doing blow and Jack Nicholson is
banging these fuckers and ah,
it's just,
that's the place,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
I think that that plays just caters.
I mean,
as soon as you walk in,
it's like this and it's dark,
thick curtains.
No cops.
Do you want know what I mean?
We'll watch the old guard the door.
Yeah.
Uh,
but I think there are places that have
magic in them.
I think that there are places that you
can't,
you just can't explain like muscle
shoals,
you know,
we cut a record in muscle shoals.
Right.
It's magic.
Really.
They say that,
you know,
why no,
the Americans lived there and that
there's like,
you know,
it was spiritual land and.
But I mean it was,
it's special.
There's something there that you're able
to get in touch with yourself easier.
I don't know what it is.
Is this something in the recording
studio itself or is there something in
the town?
I don't think so because there were
multiple studios there and they all,
they all produce great stuff.
There's still great musicians coming out
of muscle shoals and you know,
it's just,
there are certain places that are just,
I don't know what it is,
but is it possible that those buildings,
those recording studios have memory that
there's like a something and intangible,
something you can't put on a scale,
you can't measure it because the comedy
store feels like a place with memory.
That's why I always ask because I
didn't.
I took seven years off that place and I
went back about a year and a half ago
and I still to this day I remember going
back again and going,
oh,
there's that feeling again.
Like with this,
you know,
the history.
You knew the history for.
You went into the place though.
So it was before you even got there is
magic to you?
Yes.
It was for me and most mostly shows and
I went into the studio.
It was like,
Oh man,
yeah,
that's where Eddie Hinton,
you know,
took a shit in that bathroom right
there.
And it's like,
it's like A.
I think that,
I don't know if,
if you didn't,
if somebody didn't know ahead of time
and they went in there,
they would think it was just as magic as
you do.
Yeah.
Maybe you're right.
It's one of those things that you don't
know because you have these preconceived
ideas about it that are on.
Can't see it.
That was Mecca for comedians.
So muscle shoals.
What did,
did skinner record there as well?
Um,
I think skinner skinner.
I think so.
I'm pretty sure they recorded their
rolling stones.
Recorded so many fantastic aretha
recorded there.
And uh,
I mean they cut so many tracks there.
Yeah,
I like this one spot.
Research,
like a waffle house there.
There's nothing there.
There's no reason anybody would go to
muscle shoals.
And it was the recording Mecca.
Why?
Wow.
You know what I mean?
That's not close to any major
metropolis.
It's like a,
you know.
How else,
how else do you explain that?
Well,
this guy named Rupert Sheldrake,
I think his official title of these
evolutionary biologist,
and he thinks that there's memory and
everything.
He thinks he can't.
You can't extract it,
but he thinks that there's memory in
wood,
there's a memory in stones,
there's memory and it's just like,
that's why people don't like the idea of
a haunted house.
Like we kind of inherently know that
someone,
if someone died in a house,
some some horrific tragedy took place in
the house.
That house actually has that sadness and
that feeling in it.
[inaudible].
It's a part of the house now.
Ooh.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if I believe it.
I don't either,
but I think we,
we create the history in our mind before
we even before we even get there.
You know what I mean?
That's possible.
Yeah.
I mean,
my dad,
I just got a new guitar and it was,
it was a guitar that was owned by one of
my favorite musicians of all time and
this guy named Mississippi Fred
Mcdowell,
and I swear that it's magic,
but you know,
it's just a good time.
You know what?
I can feel it.
It might be magic though.
I mean it might have something in it,
but also it might have just something in
it just because,
you know,
it was his,
so that's what I'm saying is,
I mean it's saying but if it's still,
it's still real,
right?
Like that data amount of magic because
it proved to me that someone felt it who
didn't know ahead of time but not really
because it works on you.
Like magic doesn't have to work in end.
Everybody will.
Then I would explain it that I already
thought of is magic.
Right.
So you know what I mean?
You already thought it was magic,
but because you did it is.
I don't know.
Maybe.
I don't know if I would describe that as
magic.
I don't know man.
I feel like if I had a notebook that
Richard Pryor road in where you would
never write in it,
you would save it.
That's not a good example.
But like if somebody gave me like
Richard,
if rich had a laptop and he wrote some
great shit on his laptop and then
someone sold it and I had that laptop,
I'd be like,
Holy Shit.
And magic laptop.
All of a sudden they would be matched.
Jokes are just all fire,
everything you right.
You would think like,
I have to do this laptop justice.
This is the laptop of the great one.
You know,
I have to.
This is no bullshit around with this
thing.
Yeah.
You would think about it that way.
It would be.
That's the idea behind like things being
sacred.
Is it like if things,
if you decide things are sacred than
they are sacred.
Absolutely.
It's,
it's up to you to believe and if you
treat them as sacred,
then there's and,
and life is short and if you want to
believe in magic,
then it's real.
Do you know I'm going to go run a
mountain right now.
God Damn it,
Dan.
I mean all I do everyday is go into the
studio and like
make something out of nothing.
Like,
yeah,
it feels like magic to me still.
I wake up in the morning so excited.
Do you know what I mean?
It's like,
it feels like Christmas every morning.
That's.
And that's magic to me.
I was like,
that's,
that's what,
that's what I live for.
You know,
I don't even like,
but I don't know anything else,
like I've never really had a real job,
you know,
I worked at my uncle's restaurant,
but that,
you know,
that's it.
It's all I've ever done.
Perfect.
You don't need to do.
I mean everybody's got a different path.
You don't have to do other shit.
Why do anything else?
If you still enjoy it,
he's still appreciate it.
And the music is amazing.
Why fucking times it makes it hard to
relate to other people.
Right?
You know what I mean?
Just hanging around musicians.
Only state closed all musicians.
Other ones that are fighting to find the
ones that are,
I don't know,
man.
Just me and sturgill staring at each
other in Nashville.
It's it.
Yeah.
I've been a huge fan of the black keys
for a long time,
man.
So for me to have you on is a real honor
and a real treat so that you guys are so
interesting because the music is so hard
to define like there's different styles
in different albums and it seems like
you guys go off in these really eclectic
ways and paths and there's so much
content,
like you've guys have put out so many
sought.
You're so prolific.
Yeah.
I again,
like I don't know how else to do it,
you know,
I don't know what.
I don't understand how people go into
the studio and take some fucking week to
do one song.
They don't smoke weed.
I always smoke weed,
you know.
But I've done records with no we plenty
of them,
you know.
But I still do two songs a day.
Well I think you just love it and I
think if you love something and you just
give it that energy and it's obviously
given you a lot of positive results.
The thing is I think that people get so
caught up with worrying about what other
people think.
They just like over analyze and it's so
hard to get really in touch with
something special when you're worrying
so much about everybody else.
You know what I mean?
That's a real aspect of social media
that I think some people struggle with
totally.
But it's a real thing too,
you know,
there are a lot of very opinionated,
places that review music that are very,
like into the trends,
you know what I mean?
And I can see how that can be crippling
to a kid who's just trying to like make
music.
Yeah.
Well any form criticism where people
didn't like a performance,
even if it's correct stills painful for
people to hear and if you're hearing,
if you like put together something and
then it gets reviewed by a magazine or
something and it gets poorly reviewed.
Yeah.
But not being able to take criticism as
a sign of weakness,
you know,
you have to know that you have to grow
into that.
And also music is so ridiculously
subjective and there's stuff that people
love that I can't listen to.
Sure.
And there's stuff that I love that
people like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
I mean it's just always going to be that
way.
Sure.
And you have one person's take on it and
it's the best thing ever.
And another person's take on it there.
They fell asleep halfway through.
It's weird,
you know,
there are records like that where.
But then again at the saint on on the
same hand,
it's like there are records that people
played me.
I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
I hate this.
And then five years later it's my
favorite thing.
It wasn't ready for it.
I didn't quite understand that.
I didn't,
I didn't hear it in the right setting.
Do you know what I mean?
Set.
And also what's beautiful about music
and art is that it grows with you.
It can be the best of it can really grow
with you.
Yeah.
You know?
The hearing,
the right song at the right time can
leave like a psychic imprint on.
You have that song.
You always will associate that song with
that moment.
Sure.
Powerful moments.
Things that changed forever.
How old were you when you started doing
music?
I was always around music.
My Dad had a great record collection,
always playing music.
My mom played piano and her whole family
play bluegrass.
Oh Wow.
So that's what made me want to play
music was I wanted to play music with my
uncles.
They sat around in circles and my aunt
and they would play Stanley brothers
songs and you know,
my grandma died.
We all sang around her,
her,
um,
a grave,
you know what I mean?
It's just like music is a real part of
my family.
So it's just always been there.
That must have been crazy.
You all sat around her grave and sang.
We sang her favorite songs.
Whoa.
It was really nice.
That is really nice.
Angel Band by this,
by the Stanley brothers.
It's one of my favorite songs ever.
How many people were saying six?
Wow.
Six people.
And we brought her instruments.
[inaudible] lot of crying and I'm crying
just thinking about it.
No,
no.
I mean it was,
it was her favorite thing,
you know,
it was her.
She loved to sit in the living room and
listened to her kids play music.
It's like a and it's the reason I'm here
now.
Wow.
It really is.
I mean,
because music is just really been such a
part of my life.
Well,
that's awesome.
When someone finds something that they
really just tune into like that,
then you see him just pursuing it with
such wild abandon.
I mean,
that's,
that's what everybody as a fan,
that's what someone hopes for the most,
that the person who puts out the sound
that you love is really into it and does
it all the time.
Yeah.
No,
it's been the only thing I can really
focus on since I was about 15.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean girls,
girls and music was pretty much it.
I stopped messing around with sports.
Really?
Yeah.
That was it.
Well,
you guys figured it out,
man.
He get that step five records before we
even had song on the radio,
so.
Yeah.
But people were already talking about it
before you guys had songs on the radio.
You had such an authentic sound that you
had already had a lot of momentum,
but it was.
It was the cool thing too,
like that no one knew about yet.
It was.
We had a great fan base before we had a
radio success.
Yeah,
we.
We've been really blessed like every,
every year.
It was better than the one before.
What is your take on what's going on now
with radio?
Because it,
it's.
It must be strange to watch this
business go from being something where
you buy an actual physical thing to
digital downloads and mean what has it
been like to watch us all moving to the
Internet?
It's pretty depressing.
It's really depressing.
I don't think people can make
connections with music like they used
to.
You know,
when you used,
when you own something and you sit with
it and listened,
you know,
you're like sad.
I had uncles to disposable.
Yeah.
You know,
like sitting down with an album and
opening the album,
putting the headphones on and not even
talk about how,
you know,
how the artists are treated with
streaming.
I mean,
it's just,
it's totally criminal with a streaming
things weird,
right?
It's criminal to explain it.
I mean,
I don't know,
like I couldn't tell you numbers,
but you know,
I mean just like youtube,
you know,
they just paid ours fractions of what
they should be paying and it's just,
it's not treated like a real um,
valued thing anymore.
You know what I mean?
Well,
we were discussing this the other day
about streaming services that one of the
weirdest things about it is all they're
selling is artists work,
right?
Mean,
that's all you have.
You can't stream anything if someone
creates it,
that's all you have.
So that is what you're selling so well,
who's making all the money and why and
what's,
you know,
what is,
how has that worked out?
And right now there's a lot of
opportunism going on and a lot of people
are jockeying for a better slice of the
pie in a better position.
But we were talking about spotify and
all those different things and how
little money the artists actually get
out of it.
It's weird.
It is weird.
It is weird,
isn't it?
I mean,
can you imagine like going playing gigs
at the Moore Theater and then saying,
oh,
we're just going to pay you a streaming
money,
not the real gig money.
You know what I mean?
It would be like,
that would make no sense.
Right?
I mean it's Kinda the same thing.
I mean,
you,
you have a product that you invested
your time and money into.
It should be no different really.
Right.
I think there should be some sort of
established number.
You should be able to figure out how
much money are they making from it,
like how much money they make and if
they play your one of your albums.
True.
Do you know streaming.
Streaming?
Yeah.
Zero,
zero,
five cents per click
point zero,
zero,
five cents for a click for them.
And if you buy the album,
how much is it per song?
How much are they paying for?
So
sure.
For,
for a physical copy,
if you buy the album like on itunes or
on
CD,
cd or Itunes,
what is the difference?
What's the comparison to those?
You have a song is ninety nine cents.
You're looking at 30,
40 seconds,
no one can hear you,
but he said if the song is ninety nine
cents,
you're looking at 30 or forty cents.
[inaudible] think as compared to
streaming,
which is.
What'd you say at one?
Zero,
zero,
zero five.
Is that what you said?
Per time songs clicked.
Oh,
per time.
Songs clicks or every time someone
clicks on it,
it has to play for like 10 seconds.
Oh God.
It's just mass consumption.
It's weird.
Yeah.
Well,
it all started with being able to put it
on a server somewhere.
Right?
It all started from being digital.
That's where things got odd where you
could take someone stuff and you don't
need any special recording equipment to
make copies.
You make copy on your computer
instantaneously.
You upload the copy and then
that copy shared by x amount of people
who just continually download it and
share it.
Things gets weird.
They get real weird when it becomes a
digital entity,
something that's out there in space and
then figuring out how you make money off
of it,
but I would feel like a streaming
platform.
All they have is someone's work.
If,
if no one lets them put their stuff up,
then they don't have anything.
Right?
Yeah.
Like the only benefit for you guys,
it'd be more exposure,
which would help like ticket sales,
you know,
the,
the major record labels own portions of
these streaming services to.
Oh,
it gets pretty deep.
I mean it's,
it's uh,
it's just intertwined.
Nastiness and the artist pretty much
falls at the bottom of the barrel.
So the record labels have done the same
thing that they used to do with physical
records and now they've done it with the
streaming thing.
They just hamstrings everybody.
Wow,
that's great.
So should people not use those streaming
services?
Is that the way to go?
I mean ultimately probably artists
probably shouldn't allow it,
but it's like,
um,
you can't.
Yeah.
You know,
you have to put it on there.
I Dunno.
So I should've,
I should've come with a spreadsheet and
it's like,
do you have the option?
Yeah.
So like when they come to you and they
say,
Hey dan,
we would want to put all your lily and
you can say no,
thank you.
Yeah,
I see that.
What you say or do you let them put it
up there?
We don't have anything on title,
you know,
but we,
uh,
we have it on itunes.
They still pay it.
Then they pay the highest royalty rate,
right?
A itunes.
Yeah.
How's Google play?
Because they're doing that.
I don't have no idea.
That's the newest one.
I have no idea.
You know,
Google kind of they call own youtube so
they get all that youtube money.
Right.
But don't they have to pay for like
bandwidth and shit too?
Is,
isn't all that expensive?
I don't know.
Yeah,
but it's weird.
It's weird how the world has changed.
It's like I'm a musician now,
I have to worry about fucking this
business side of shit now and we all
have to like know about who owns all
these little portions of this shit.
I mean it's like that's why we get taken
advantage of because we're just trying
to be artists and trying to make music.
We have to come become college
professors to even figure out our record
deals.
Do you know what I mean?
It's really unfair and when you sign a
kid to a record deal,
it's like they,
they pretty much are signing their life
on the line,
you know,
I'm sure you've read that piece that
Courtney love wrote years back.
I don't think I've ever read anything.
It was pretty famous because a lot of
people accused or using a ghost writer
because it was so well done,
but it was a piece breaking down.
Like if you didn't know that she was the
one who wrote it,
you would go,
Whoa,
this is a scathing review of how the
money is distributed in the record
business.
And uh,
it was pretty shocking when you look at
it from terms of actual revenue to what
actually trickles down to the artist was
the only thing that they're selling.
The artists work and how these,
these contracts are set up to fuck
people over.
But they've been around forever.
And there's these giant machines,
right?
They have so many employees and they
kind of have to justify keeping all
these buildings and having all these
employees and there's a lot of money
that needs to be earned.
Just to keep this thing floating.
Right?
Well,
it got so engorged.
Yeah.
It's a tech at the height of physical
sales,
right?
Yeah.
It's,
it's hard to like get used to a certain
lifestyle.
Right.
I mean,
you're going to move back into apartment
next week and yeah,
it would suck you.
Wouldn't you try to figure out how to.
You might cut his pay a little bit.
Maybe the officers that you know,
that's what they did.
Yeah.
They just wanted to.
Well,
they had to downsize quite a bit.
I used to love record stores.
I mean the last real job I had was in a
record store.
Really last time I was ever really taxed
before being a musician.
I worked at quonset hut records in
Akron,
Ohio and it was awesome.
I learned so much there.
I learned so much cool shit.
People hit me with so much great music
that I never would have heard of.
Well back then.
That was the way you could find out
about it.
You go to the record stores and
efficient autos would let you know about
dedicated their lives to learning about
this stuff.
You know what I mean,
like essentially college professors of
music.
Yeah.
The guys that I worked with were pretty
much geniuses.
They were all like 45,
55 year old guys with like other living
room is just all records,
you know what I mean?
And they would teach me things every
time I would go in there like,
oh,
so you've never heard this?
Well then you got to hear this and you
got to hear this.
And it changed me.
You know,
isn't it funny that that is not like a
respected quality in the mainstream
world,
but being a Somalia is,
you know what I mean?
Being a guy who can like swish wine
around and tell you what part of France
it was grown like that's,
that's something that we look at it and
go,
oh he's a sophisticated Somalia.
But like,
oh that dude,
he knows a lot about sixties jazz.
Nobody gives a shit.
Nobody gives a shit you loser.
I don't give a shit about Somalia and
stuff.
So I mean,
I don't know,
you got to come up with a different
comparison,
but you know what I mean,
like for a lot of people it's sure it's
a,
it's a big fancy schmancy type.
Well,
you know,
I mean it's all,
it's all a bunch of horse shit.
I mean it's like just because you don't
have a college degree in it.
Yeah,
it's not taken seriously.
But what really is a college degree at
the end of the day?
Well,
when it comes to music,
I mean imagine if the only good
musicians were musicians who had phds
and in music theory,
no,
it would be like North Korea.
I mean,
could you even put together the kind of
music that you guys made?
If,
if you really like thought about it in
that way,
like your,
your stuff is so uniquely creative,
you know what like you have,
you guys had a sound for a lot of your
songs so it's like you would,
you would hear it and even though it was
interesting and unique and different
from the previous song,
you could tell us a black key song.
It was,
it was coming from two guys,
you know,
clearly coming from two guys.
I think as soon as you add a lot of
theory and overproduction and different
people overseeing things and looking for
the right amount of beats per minute and
all that jazz.
Listen man,
it's like the greatest people are just
the greatest people.
When you,
if you could be around Richard Pryor,
watch him.
You would feel the magic.
You would see the way he walks,
the way he touches his lips,
the way he,
you know,
like when I'm hanging out with Dr John,
I see it.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
this guy is like from another planet.
You know what I mean?
He just,
you can't teach that.
It's just,
it's total magic.
You know?
I can't even imagine like an la Dr John
used to be here,
so doing session work fit well.
That's like when Phil Spector was making
records and stuff like that,
you know,
it would be a studio full of Dr Johns.
People that just had their own,
their own thing about him.
You know what I mean?
Total self confidence,
their own style.
No theory,
no bullshit.
It was just like,
this is,
this is what he does and we're going to
incorporate this and this with 12 other
guys who have their own thing.
It's like magic.
You know what I mean?
And that's a cool thing that studios
would kind of lose now because people
can't afford to have studios and things
had changed so much.
Over time it gets depressing the more I
work with these older,
older guys who are just insane.
It's just so hard to describe.
It really is.
It feels like magic.
Was it because everything they were
doing was completely analog?
No,
because it was a performance and you
need to like not only did you have to
come up with the part on the spot,
it had to kind of improvise.
You had to play perfectly behind the
beat.
You had to like,
you had to just like,
I don't.
It's just hard to explain.
You had to just kind of be able to
understand the nuance of everything
going on around you and there's less of
that now.
I think that it's harder when people
don't get to record together and make
music together,
which is the case,
you know what I mean?
Because it's.
You don't really make money make playing
music unless you reach a certain level
and it's so much harder to now than it
ever was before.
It's harder to reach a certain level.
Yeah.
It's just.
But doesn't youtube and things along
those lines don't.
Doesn't it help some people reach a
higher level quicker without the need
for mainstream media?
I don't know.
You don't know?
Beats me.
I don't know anybody who like got their
start on youtube,
didn't honey honey band.
Then they become famous from youtube.
I think that's what started all about.
It's a combination of things.
It's hard to nail down on one.
Yeah.
I mean we didn't do that but I mean we
were like hit the road and we like
playing shows and we just kept hitting
up city so I just,
I wouldn't know because I don't know.
I don't have experience with that.
So tell me about the arcs.
Will the arts is just a group of Friends
of mine who I made records with for
years,
guys who make some of my favorite
records,
Leon Michaels,
Richard Swift.
I'm Hammerstein Weisen and nick motion.
They're just great musicians,
you know,
and uh,
we've made different records together
in,
in various forms for different people.
And then when we had free time we would
record for ourselves just for fun,
just making stuff up.
And I'm Leon and I about a year and a
half ago got together just to like
categorize them,
put them in a folder to see what we had
and we had like 70 songs while we're
just sitting there.
So we're like,
what are we doing you now,
let's,
uh,
figure out a way to like share this
music.
And um,
so we just kind of came up with the rx
and that was our platform that's
insanely had 70 songs,
70 songs.
Yeah.
I mean,
every time we get in the studio together
with two or three songs,
we'll just,
we can just make them up,
you know?
Wow.
When you go into the studio,
do you have any idea?
If you are,
if you're in a session where you might
improvise and come up with new stuff,
do you have any idea of what direction
you're going to go in or do you have a
concept or do you just go free ball?
You kind of.
I had just always a free freewill I
guess.
Have you always done it that way?
Yeah,
so for the most part.
I mean I,
I don't,
I have had some songs written ahead of
time,
but that's more recently when I started
it,
we were just making shit up.
I mean black,
he's out there just totally improvised.
And so when you improvise,
would you have someone recording it as
you're doing it or would you write it?
We did it all ourselves.
So in the basement it was just the two
of us and we had a four track cassette
recording them.
Yeah,
like a digital recorder.
Um,
yeah.
No,
I mean we didn't have anybody helping us
while.
Well that's why I was so cool.
I mean that's why it was such a,
you know,
there's hubs,
the I'll do big sessions now and
there'll be like an assistant running
around like taking notes,
like what guitar I'm using and Shit,
and I'm like,
oh this track.
So interesting now,
but it's just,
I just never had that growing up.
It just feel so weird.
So would you guys,
would you guys recorded initially as you
were improvising error or did you
improvise it and get it down and then
record it and improvise it?
Usually.
Usually like,
uh,
the first or second take is,
is the one that's best.
Even with the mistakes,
it has the best feeling for me.
The more that you focus on stuff to
them,
I guess the more boring it gets.
You lose that like initial spark to what
a fucking cool life you have.
You make cool and then you release them.
I'm not complaining.
Fuck man.
It's so cool the way you describe it to
you just kind of go in there and fall
into the trance and make the sounds.
And for me it's only gotten better.
The feeling.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I work harder than anybody I know.
I get up in the morning,
I started working and I don't work until
I'm asleep.
I don't stop falling asleep,
you know,
everyday.
So I think if it is work or do you think
of it is like when I get paid,
I think if it is work,
but one of them doing it,
I never think of it as work.
So when the checks come it's worked
well.
It was,
must have done some work while you're
doing work.
It's just passion.
Like how would you describe it?
Yeah,
it's pet.
I feel so lucky being able to go into
the studio.
I love hearing shit like this man go and
living in Nashville too,
which is a place that is music city USA,
you know,
I mean,
you could argue that rock and roll
started there with,
you know,
pretty woman.
Aaron,
Aaron Room,
right.
That riff was done.
Wayne Moss did that riff right down the
street.
Um,
uh,
you know,
it's just like,
I just love that stuff.
I love learning from those guys.
I love being around that.
It's just so much fun for me.
You know,
I had um,
wheeler Walker Jr in here the other day
and uh,
we were talking about Nashville and he
was talking about the money machine
being behind Nashville now and how
strange it is that you have some real
music in that town,
but then you also have this stuff that
is just concocted because it looks like
it would do numbers and Walmart.
Yeah.
But you know,
we're,
doesn't that happen on some,
at some level it's a music business.
Yeah.
You're always going to have that,
right?
Yeah.
It's a business.
I mean,
you're always going to have douche holes
making a lot of money,
a lot more money than you.
You know what I mean?
But the thing that,
that's so great about that,
I don't fucking ever see that.
I'm never around that.
I don't fuck with that at all.
You know what I mean?
And I've been in Nashville six years,
seven years,
something like that.
But the thing that's so cool about that
is they really do a hold up that
infrastructure and like if I run out of
tape,
I make a phone call and somebody
delivers me reel to reel tape and like
10 minutes.
Really?
Where else can you do that happened?
You know what I mean?
If that big business wasn't going on,
it wouldn't make it so easy for me to be
around so many great musicians.
A lot of these country guys that I work
with,
um,
you know,
they're embarrassed with some of the
shit that they play on.
They won't tell me how bad it is,
but,
but it's the reason they're there and
healthy and able to come in and work
with me,
you know what I mean?
So you can't complain about it and then
reap all the benefits,
you know what I mean?
So I understand that.
Just like positive negatives,
that's very honest of you.
That's a good way of looking at it too.
That's a very good perspective because
it's not like it hurts you.
You know,
if you drive down the street,
a burger
king,
it doesn't hurt you.
If you don't go in there and eat,
I,
I'm,
I make a living playing music and
Nashville and I never see it.
That's interesting.
Well you just surround yourself with a
tight knit group.
I guess.
I never leave home,
so that's.
I never see it.
Yeah.
Nashville is for,
for a lot of musicians.
Like that is the,
that's the remaining Mecca,
right.
Um,
well for,
for certain musicians,
people who love country and Bluegrass,
it's definitely the place to be,
you know,
bluegrass still lives in Nashville more
than anywhere else I'd say.
It seems like this is a really good time
for country.
It seems our country is experiencing a
resurgence right now.
Like real country.
Yeah.
I think that um,
I have no idea really.
I don't know what to say about that.
No,
you're in the mix though.
He's going to say something stupid about
people buying records.
Walmart behind them or whatever.
That's very nice of you to pull back
out.
It wouldn't look at me getting smart
with age.
It's also,
uh,
we'd,
we'd have to be double,
triple thinking stuff.
I pull it back,
son.
No need for conflict.
No,
I mean,
uh,
I mean it's,
you know,
country,
country fans buy more out,
more physical copies than anyone.
Oh really?
By far.
Yeah.
No kidding.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Really?
They probably still use CD things.
Probably have those.
Walkmans was mega big hip ones with the
big bellies yelling the neat things.
Always yellow.
Yeah,
that's good question.
And they just like,
yeah,
that could never be black fellows.
Yellow.
I was true.
It's like hazard.
There was always like a hazard to them
or something like there were big.
All I wanted was that big yellow disc
and the Tony Hawk skateboard.
It's like all I ever wanted.
Well I remember when they figured out a
way to have some sort of buffering so
that when you were playing the cd you
could actually jump around a little bit
and move and it wouldn't skip.
It was crazy.
What did that feel when that happened
to,
for that?
Yes.
P Esp ten second esp if that's right.
Yeah.
It was a buffering that they had seen.
There was a magical thing.
Skip protection,
something,
something electronic.
Skip protection is what it is.
It is.
And then once they figured out how to go
digital,
all that shit tied.
Can you imagine these have record
players in cars?
Did it for real?
Some early cars.
Used to have the option.
Wow.
My friend Javier,
his mom had an eight track and never
forgot who listened to Pablo Cruz.
While my baby smiles at me,
I go to Rio and it was in those eight
track things like this is a.
What is crazy space age contraption.
This lady has an.
Her car is pushed this box in there and
it plays music.
It was amazing.
You know.
Oh look at this.
This is crazy.
Here you go.
We're looking at a woman playing 40
fives in her car.
What kind of car is it?
That was a record player.
This is nuts.
That is nuts.
It's a record player where the ashtray
sort of would be in a conventional car.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Every two and a half minutes you have to
like look down and flip a record.
Can you imagine those old cars?
Man?
There was something about those old cars
too.
There were.
There were a rolling piece of artwork as
well.
There was some design and art to them
that just you can't once you started
going with aerodynamics and miles per
gallon and airbags and shit happening on
the dash.
Yeah.
There's something with those cars.
It's just so extraordinary.
I got to see the car the other day with
this digital touchscreen thing.
It was like Tesla was a tesla.
No,
I've never been in a tesla.
I don't remember what it was,
but it was just so weird.
Yet a lot of the electric cars have real
crazy setups now.
Very strange.
Yeah.
The Tesla is a giant screen,
like an enormous laptop screen,
like a big computer screen.
Like that's what a tesla screen looks
like.
I mean,
it's like a crazy laptop though.
That's not a distraction,
isn't by the way you can get email on
that and websites.
It's like,
show me my flight path.
You can,
you can do all that kind of stuff.
You can do spotify on that to where you
can press a little button and ask it to,
uh,
you know,
play Michael Jackson and it'll play
Michael Jackson songs.
It's so stupid.
It's so big.
It's a totally flat screen and you can
judge man.
Is that a youtube video?
That guy's in the right hand side.
You can play youtube videos where you
drive.
Oh,
that's so dangerous.
Did you see that guy that got killed in
Detroit?
He was jacking off in his car.
He crashed his car with his pants down.
Died in the accident.
He was watching porn Jackin off as he
was driving.
And the state troopers,
when they got to the wreck due to his
pants down.
Porn playing?
No.
Oh Man.
His kids in the eyes in rec watching
porn.
Did they make their user's name?
Clifford Ray Jones partially ejected
through the sun roof when his 19,
96 Toyota rolled and he was thrown from
the vehicle and died.
He wasn't wearing pants.
Police told the Detroit News.
Oh,
well,
driver inattention is leading factor in
most crashes and near crashes.
Okay,
wait a second.
What was he doing?
Was He watching a movie?
Who's jacking off?
He was watching porn was pants off.
This said it was in [inaudible] 96
Corolla.
Where the fuck did you get that screen
in there?
Well,
he had it in his phone.
He was watching porn on his phone and
jerking off.
Oh God.
Kids an animal.
He was 58.
Oh my God.
You Retard.
Well,
he should have known better old people
in electronics,
man.
Yeah.
That wasn't figured.
It wasn't because he was choking up.
It was just because he was old.
May Be.
You never know.
Are you a car guy you into cars?
No,
not really.
No.
I mean I've got a couple of cars,
but now a couple of old cars.
I just.
What I figured you for,
I figured you feel like an mg or
something.
Like I've got an old Ford panel van that
I drive around town.
You know?
Panel van?
Yeah.
Nineteen 60.
Were you talking about like wood panels
on the side?
No,
just agreeing work truck.
You know,
with the barn doors that opened in the
back.
Really?
Yeah.
I used to deliver newspapers in one of
those.
I had a dodge just like A.
I love it man.
What do you drive a van for?
It's not like a van,
it looks like a,
it looks pretty cool.
Yeah.
I mean it's kind of beat up.
I don't have to worry about it.
Does that,
why you like it or b,
you could score stuff here.
All my equipment in it,
you know,
it's really easy to holds five people
and if people want to sit in the back of
hold is 10,
you know,
I don't know.
So Dude,
you're just all about getting your music
done.
You don't give a fuck.
You driving around a panel van getting
all beat up.
I bought a new BMW like uh,
four years ago.
I still have it.
It's starting to fall apart already.
Really?
I,
yeah.
All these things keep flashing and like,
do you take it and get the notices in
the mail?
You know,
notice is like really?
Meg May shoot shrapnel and you know,
it's like,
what model bmw did you get?
Um,
it's a uh,
uh,
what's it called?
Thex x five x five.
It's a diesel.
Okay.
That's,
that's your problem.
Which is a total pain in the ass trying
to find diesel gas.
So that's gross to me.
Well,
the only thing about diesel,
that's cool as you could grow your own
like um.
Oh,
I grew up my own.
Do you make your own needs?
Oh No,
no,
no.
Nobody goes,
does nobody grows around?
Do you know Neil young does?
No,
he doesn't.
He makes his own biodiesel.
He pays somebody to grow his own diesel.
He makes money off it.
Okay.
Um,
you might be right,
but I think he was trying to be self
sustaining though.
So he might not be selling maybe is.
That's cool.
He,
he's got some amazing cars.
Yeah.
He has a gigantic ranch in northern
California and uh,
he does grow his own bio diesel and he
has his car is converted to,
to use it.
Yeah,
right.
I've heard about that ranch.
Like he,
he bought it early on the farmer.
Yeah.
And he has some crazy sound system set
up on his lake where you can get in a
boat.
Allegedly.
Someone told us this,
I believe on the podcast and he gets out
on this boat and he has the sound system
set up where the acoustics are perfect.
When he's in the middle of this pond
that he has,
and so he has he speakers set up on the
side and around the pond and it just
blast the perfect sound that echoes off
the water epic.
Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He's the reason why I had to quit work
at security at a great woods in
Mansfield,
Massachusetts when I was 19,
cause a riot broke out during a neil
young concert because people were
lighting fires.
If you ever been a great woods,
do you know the great woods performance
center is?
Maybe it's an outdoor amphitheater.
Yeah,
it's an amphitheater.
It's covered up into the back area,
which is called the lawn in the back
area
was literally like a sweeping law in,
in those cheap proceeds.
Sure.
And when Neil young was there,
people started fires there.
They just started lighting garbage on
fire and then fights broke out and then
it was just chaos and I had a jacket.
I put a Hoodie on over my security guard
jacket.
I fucking put my hoodie on.
I was like,
I quit.
Walked out of there like fuck this place
and I'll never forget the last hour
worked with during the Neil Young
concert and as I was leaving people were
punching people and there was fire and I
was like,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Yeah.
I've worked at one of those
amphitheaters blossom music center.
Oh yeah.
Where's that?
Outside of Cleveland.
Richfield.
Another Ohio boy right there.
You know,
blossom music center.
Yeah.
Columbus.
I used to.
Me and my buddies used to be the guys in
the parking lot with flags.
Why are so many bad motherfuckers from
Ohio?
What's going on?
Why is that state so bad ass?
I don't know.
I think that it had a,
I think that had a lot of money,
uh,
with all the industry,
so it had a lot of art.
But now that now that the industry is
gone,
it's kind of,
it's a struggle a bit,
but the art still there,
right?
The NFL,
the culture,
right.
Understanding that there's respect for
art,
I think.
I Dunno,
I just totally made that up.
But you might be right.
That might make sense that,
that sounds.
There's something,
there's something,
there's a bunch of astronauts are from
Ohio,
tons of famous,
a lot of people I've met just here since
I've lived here from Ohio.
Just hanging around and whatnot is a bad
ass place.
Do standup too.
It's one of my favorite places.
One of the,
um,
one of the female astronauts who died in
the challenger explosion was from,
with my high school.
Where was that?
Female astronauts from that war.
The diaper that went to the guy's house
to kill him.
She wore the diaper to drive all the way
across the country.
So she didn't have to stop the PPI.
Some girl or something.
I remember that girl is willing to
fucking wear astronaut charged with
attempted murder anytime.
A chick as willing to wear a diaper.
You fucked her up so bad.
She wants to wear a diaper
to come and get you.
I mean,
would you think that a female astronaut
would like,
she doesn't play games.
She wants to win.
Not plugins.
You've got the right stuff,
dude.
Absolutely.
Arrival for another astronauts.
Affection.
Yeah.
She attacked a rival for another
astronauts affection the Orlando
International Airport on Monday after
driving more than 900 miles from Houston
to meet her flight.
Whoa.
Okay.
So this girl was flying and this crazy
bitch said,
I'm on a fucking meet you.
They're wearing a diaper shitting
herself.
She only had a four inch blade and a bb
gun though.
She's an astronauts.
All she needs,
she kill that bitch with a pop.
Know that astronauts knew how to kill
people.
They teach you that.
They're Americans.
Goddammit.
They learn.
Um,
I wonder,
man,
I wonder what she knew.
Maybe she just wanted to close our eyes
or something.
Just bite her in the face or something.
Yikes.
Maybe she didn't really want to kill
her.
She had a bb gun though.
And a map to the house.
Well,
listen,
anybody who's wearing a diaper ain't
thinking that straight.
Maybe she knows the BB gun when she
picked it up.
It's awesome.
She had a map to the house x.
well,
do you know the story about the guy who
broke into the White House?
Only one guy ever broken the White House
during the Obama Administration and I've
been researching.
Is he the only one who's ever broken
that one ever during the Obama?
Yeah.
He had in his car two,
two rifles for hand guns.
800 rounds of ammunition to hatchets and
a machete and he broke into the White
House with a knife on him and he only
got 18 months.
That's what's really crazy.
They said,
well,
he had ptsd.
Oh,
okay.
It's called the roof like plead deal.
We bars to the door and there was a
woman security guard and she couldn't
stop him.
He was too big and he ran past her and
he got deep in.
You got deep in the White House,
like deeper than they had originally
admitted.
Did he?
Uh,
did he have a map like with x at the
end?
That's what it was going to say.
He had a map like White House x is dumb.
Fuck,
this guy was completely out of his mind.
But the crazy thing is the only got 18
months.
Like I know a guy was in jail for 10
years for growing weed.
He's in federal penitentiary for 10
years for growing weed and this guy got
18 months for having an arsenal in his
car and breaking into the White House
with a knife.
Idiocracy man.
You see that cop in New York just got a
convicted of manslaughter but didn't get
any jail time.
Which comp.
Which story just just happened the other
day.
I forget.
Do you know what the case was?
I think it was at one of those cases
where he had the duty where he was in
like consorted patrolling the stairwells
and projects,
which sounds horrifying.
No jail time for x and y PD officer
after manslaughter conviction reduced to
criminally negligent homicide.
Huh?
What does it say?
And he did Jamie.
I'm just saying it's like seems like
everyday there's just something that
doesn't make any sense.
Well,
there's definitely a lot of stuff that
doesn't make any sense and also a lot of
stuff you have to deal with if you're a
fucking cop.
I think this is a subject that requires
balance.
I think there's a lot of terrible things
at cops had done and it's obvious you've
seen videos of it.
We saw that cop shoot that guy in the
back running away and then throw the
Taser on them.
We've all seen horrible shift seeing it.
I think these guys are shellshocked.
I think there's a vast majority of the
people out there that are operating as
police officers that are barely keeping
it together.
I think it's a hard job and I think
those guys are under stress all the
time.
Every day might be the end of their
life.
Every car they pull over might be
someone who shoots him.
You walk into places and you're hated
instantly,
instantly everybody's line.
It shouldn't be the opposite.
Yeah,
everybody's lying to and on top of that,
they've set up as the enemy and as the
enemy by making them glorified revenue
collector's pulling people over for
having a fucking traffic ticker.
You know your,
your,
your blinkers not working or you were
licensed plates expired all shit.
That has nothing to do with crime.
You know?
I think there's a lot of that going on
where they give them quotas on speeding
tickets and they turned them into the
enemy.
You're taking money from people,
you're stealing from people.
They're being used,
they're being used and.
Yeah,
and it's not right.
I just always hope that with when people
talk about stuff like this and all these
videos that are getting out and people
the awareness of it,
that it'll bounce back the other way.
Then people will realize it and the
people somehow or another,
it'll be a self correcting thing.
You think that's going to happen?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
They don't think it's in time.
The things that are self correcting A.
I think it's some famous white person
has to die and then maybe it'll get
corrected.
Oh,
white people.
I see.
Hmm.
Might be.
It might be right.
Yeah.
It seems to be when people take notice.
I saw that interview that you did with
that ex Baltimore cop.
Yeah.
He's coming back in.
Boy that that was like,
that should be,
um,
required viewing.
Yeah.
He's running for.
I'm chief of police of Chicago.
He wants to take over Chicago.
He thinks he can make some leeway.
He's going to come in and talk about
that.
That's what an uphill battle that would
be.
Well,
if anybody's going to do it,
it's going to be a guy like him.
A radical thinker.
I don't mean fighting the crime.
I mean,
I mean changing the politics.
Yeah,
that would be the uphill battle,
but both would be a problem.
You know,
Chicago became a blood bath after they
started arresting key gang members that
were in control of a drug distribution.
So they created a power vacuum and you
know,
much like hats happened.
Isn't that why they call it rec?
What's that?
Isn't that why they call it Cerec?
Is that what they call it?
Yeah,
well they call it rec.
You knew that Jamie is on black twitter
on a regular basis.
We just came out.
He called it that too.
That was in the SPEC.
That's what they call it.
That's what locals call it.
I'm so white because it was a little war
zone.
Yeah.
It isn't more zone,
but it's essentially.
I didn't know that,
but it seems like kind of the same thing
where you take out people in power and
then it's just chaos.
Well,
we were there,
um,
about a year and a half ago and there
was a guy who,
uh,
I was talking with down there that used
to be a cop and now he was a limo driver
and uh,
he was telling me what it was like and
that it's always been a problem.
He's like,
but then when they decided to go in and
make some key arrests,
they had created a bit of a power vacuum
and then it all ramped up where people
were trying to.
And then there was also like,
once the violence has wrapped up,
then people want to respond to that
violence and it ramps it up even more.
And how do you stop that,
you know,
I mean,
but if anybody knows it's going to be a
guy like Michael Wood.
It's going to be a guy who was a former
cop,
worked in Baltimore who understood.
Is he thinking about drugs as you think
they're going to need to be legalized?
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
I don't think he's in locking up for
anything that they want to do.
I think everybody agrees to that.
I mean this,
there's those nonviolent crimes.
To have these prisons filled up with
nonviolent crimes is very bizarre,
especially when it's not violent.
It's embarrassing.
It's embarrassing to be embarrassed.
We should be.
We fucking run so many people's lives
and it doesn't look good.
They're going to do anything about it.
People make too much money.
Well,
people with political influence,
well,
private prisons just.
And then when that judge got caught in
Pennsylvania for taking young kids and
locking them up in jail for money and
that he was getting some sort of a
kickback from these detention institutes
where they would send young juvenile
detention.
Man,
I'm just to know that there's people out
there that are working in justice that
would be willing to take money and
sacrifice.
I'm young kids future.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's really,
really scary that these are the people
that we made justice to.
That's heinous.
I mean,
I,
I get so scared thinking about my kids.
Uh,
you know,
I mean,
every single day you see crazy shit.
You know,
you see something like,
you know,
black kid killed by a cop.
You know,
it's like Jesus Christ.
It's like never ending.
It does make me kind of want to not
leave my house.
Sometimes it's awful,
but it's also off of black kids,
killed by black kids,
white kids killed by white violence in
and of itself.
It's such a it at this point,
not not realize I'm only ever,
I only ever going to Worldstar or you
should get off.
My favorite video worldstar was this
week to the one with the little cub
wrestling a dog.
Jesus Christ.
I didn't see this little baby bear.
Fuck this dog up.
Who was a grown dog man.
It's a little tiny bear and it looked
like the dog was fucking with the bear
and then the bears like Fitch just
grabbed it by his head and just ragdoll
at them.
It's on my instagram.
It is crazy.
Like you can't believe how strong this
little tiny bear is in comparison to a
full grown dog that's twice the size.
He's throws them around like,
look at this,
look at this dog is fucking.
Was like bitch,
yikes.
Like he just,
he's.
He ragdoll says dog wash.
The dog gets out,
watch his hip toss.
Watch this ad right here.
Boom,
dude.
That's technique.
Look like,
take control.
That dog knows what the fuck is going on
or that bear rather.
Wait a second.
Play that again and do the commentary.
That was cool.
I'll show you exactly what's going on
here.
See the dogs fuck with.
He's like,
no bitch.
He got the Thai clinch.
First of all,
it gets the plum around the neck.
Ragdoll them to the ground.
Dogs.
Try to reach around behind him.
He had just flips a dog on his back and
they looked at hip toss.
The hip toss at the end is huge.
He's got the scarf hold.
Hold it on that thing.
It's huge.
It's huge because that's.
He established his position.
He did and he gave it up very quickly,
but well because he's smart.
He knew it was going to get reversed.
Well,
I apparently the doug has jujitsu and he
wanted to stay so big.
He's a goon.
They wanted to keep it up.
The dogs are goon.
The bear's going to win.
Eventually it's going to.
He's going to have to cook
them.
It's going to take some time,
but trust me,
the bad I got my dog is a goon.
Yeah,
he's a good good.
How dare you.
Goon is when you roll with someone and
they're not good.
They're just strong and they throw you
off of them.
You just got to ride the boat.
You've got to figure out a way to ride.
Isn't it like most people with big
muscles though?
A lot of people who have big muscles.
I mean I'm a boxing fan and like when
somebody walks in to the ring and they
bet a lot of muscles,
I pretty much automatically know they're
going to lose.
I got two words for you,
Mike Tyson.
That's what you get when you get big
muscles and intelligence and a
knowledge,
a deep knowledge of boxing.
You totally both things,
but most of the time you don't.
Most of the time you don't,
but when you did like when Mike Tyson
was in its prime,
it was so terrifying because there
wasn't a guy like that before.
Him is super fast.
Ridiculously powerful.
Guy Just came in with perfect technique,
bobbing and weaving,
throwing bombs at you.
Ooo,
yeah,
his side to side movement was just so
terrifying.
That little bear with fuck him up.
Grab a hold of his dick from the ground.
Flip him over on his back.
I don't know man.
You seen him with his tigers?
Yeah,
he's crazy.
Charlie Murphy had one of the funniest
stories ever.
Told them this podcast we told about how
he pulled up to Mike Tyson's house with
a bunch of his friends and they're all
in limos and nobody wanted to get out of
the car because Mike Tyson was on the
front lawn with a fucking lion.
He's kept thinking line and he's.
He's got a lot of actual real life.
Nobody wanted to get it out of the car.
Where was the tiger?
Was it a lion?
One of those things,
but it's an animated thing.
Oh,
he's got a tiger there.
He had a gang of cats.
How rich do you have to get before you
start clicking the zoo?
Animals,
but he was insane.
Wealthy living in Vegas,
I mean at the test seems to be the thing
like you got lucky.
You get a lot of fighters wind up
getting very dangerous animals.
I was a.
That was a big thing with a lot of
fighters.
I was just wondering what did he do with
these things once he couldn't handle it
and find it.
Like who?
What kind of animals?
A lot of boxers get a pit bulls.
That's real common.
A lot of uh,
kickboxers MMA fighters get bulls.
Yeah.
Real comment.
They just want to be around something
that's as bad asses them.
Sure.
You know,
or makes them feel and insist they're
safe.
Yeah.
Well you'll be safe to other people that
you have to worry about if you have a
pit bull most of the time you're safe.
If it's your dog.
It's very rare that a pit bull attacks
it's owner.
It's very rare.
They pleased they want to please people
and it's not even normal for them to go
after people.
Usually the only times that those dogs
go after people's.
When they're abused or totally.
I totally believe you,
but I wouldn't let my kids know that's
the children is different because
children are small and they think
children are like in my life.
So I came around.
I totally understand.
But you're saying part of everybody's
life,
so it's like when you get a pit bull,
you're basically saying I'm,
you know,
half the population can't be around me.
You could say that,
but there are,
you know,
the problem is it's not worth the risk
to make the exception,
but there are some people's dogs that
are amazing.
A Guy,
I used
to have this pit bull named Lucy.
She was the sweetest dog ever to
everybody.
She's killed babies.
It didn't match.
She loved everybody,
but you know,
when people would see her,
they'd be like,
is that a pit bull?
And they'd freak out.
She was the nicest dog ever.
But then you'll have other dogs that are
just not like that at all.
You know,
they're dangerous.
They're,
they're tricky.
And you never know because they all look
the same.
Like you'd have to get the know the dog
and you have to know the history of the
dog and the dog's parent's history and
you know,
I have this dog that's a massive and
he's a smaller massive.
It's called a regency mastermind.
He is the sweetest dog I've ever had in
my life and the reason why is because
the guy who raised them like he
wouldn't.
He described it to me.
He's like,
it's all about the parents and it's all
about not letting parents that exhibit
any weird behavior breed.
He's like,
if you're going to breed like a really
nice dog,
he just makes sure that the dogs are
always friendly and only friendly dogs
breed and if they're not friendly,
don't allow them to breathe.
I was like,
damn,
that's crazy.
He's got to completely organized that
way.
Like genetically,
no.
He makes sure that these dogs are never
any dog that growls at somebody.
Any dog that barks for no reason,
they don't breed.
Those are the ones they put in the other
barn where they secretly breed and fix
him.
He just fit.
No,
they're different dogs or daryl.
It's a large dog.
One of my friends,
his mom bread,
a bull mastiffs oh yeah.
So I was always freaked out.
Every time I went over they would like
be in the yard playing with bowling
balls,
you know,
and I'd be like,
I'm not getting out of the car.
Yeah,
they,
there are some enormous dogs.
They were originally made like they make
them,
I think for some sort of guard dog.
Right.
That was the idea behind them to make
them as big as possible.
Like those English mastiffs.
So 200 pound dogs.
They're enormous.
Yeah.
I'll get those.
I like labs.
I think labs are my favorite.
They're like the most predictable,
you know,
they're predictable.
Who's got a good month,
a good month or good man.
Is there any downside to living in
Nashville?
Like what is it?
Is it all good living down there or is
it,
you know,
there's,
there's been such an influx of people
that it's,
it's a bit congested now.
It's sort of like Austin in that regard.
Right.
Where it's,
I guess that's the hotspot.
I've heard that if you're young and you
have aspirations and you want to live in
a cool place,
it seems to take longer and longer each
year to get across town ski guys keep
talking about it,
telling people how awesome it is.
You know,
you hear me talking about me.
I just did.
I worked there all the time.
I do.
I used to do a Zany comedy club is down
there.
Should have been there a lot.
I'm there next month.
I'm doing the Ryman is just played the
ryman.
Awesome.
We had John Prine come out and sing with
us.
Now.
Are you doing the arcs in conjunction
with the black keys?
Like how do you know?
Just sort of pat and I sort of just
finished,
uh,
like the term blue tour which ended like
four years straight of touring road.
So we're just kind of taking a little
break.
I'm doing this arc,
the
arc thing now.
And when you guys do things like this,
do you do things legally or do you just
shake hands and say we're in a band and
do things legally?
Yeah,
yeah,
I do with these guys.
I love them.
They're my friends,
but they're,
you know,
they're pros.
Yeah.
You kind of have to.
Huh?
They all have their own lawyers,
you know,
because they have been ripped off,
they've been referred the past that
happens to really good musicians.
And what an amazing relationship you
could have though,
if you had a bunch of heavy duty
musicians that went in on a handshake.
We don't talk about money really ahead
of time,
you know,
they'll buy plane tickets and flying to
Nashville and spend a week recording,
will never wants to talk about contrast
or anything like that.
So it's all done at advanced on
afterwards.
It's,
you know,
hey,
we finished the record.
Let's,
we'll work it out now.
Right.
That's how it should be done.
Right?
Until you get screwed and then you're
like,
shit,
I should've done this ahead of time.
I don't know.
I think that's how it should be done,
but at least there's a level of trust
that you guys do the recording in
advance.
I mean,
that's a,
that's a high level of trust and then
figure it out afterwards.
That's a very high level of trust
because what if you guys catch
lightening in a bottle when he bitched?
Gets greedy?
Yeah.
Someone gets those.
Scrooge mcduck Ching,
Ching,
those dollar bills in his eyes and next
thing you know.
Have you guys ever had your songs ripped
off before?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
What does that feel like?
I'm strange,
you know,
I mean for,
for pat and I was like,
we spent so many years just trying to
get noticed to like have people copying
us.
It was just so bizarre.
We had this,
we had this one case where,
um,
I mean it's happened multiple times
does,
but we had this one case where a,
some casino did an advertisement and the
owner of the casino posted something on
fit on like twitter or something like,
hey,
check it out.
We just,
we just ripped off this black keys song
for a new ad.
You guys like it.
We just used that in the case and it was
insane.
Did they just not know?
I don't think he knew how the Internet
works.
I don't know.
I thought maybe he was.
Maybe he just thought posting to his
buddies.
That's hilarious.
Was it like a native American casino
where they thought they had different
laws?
I don't know because they know,
man.
Do they have different laws when it
comes to that kind of stuff?
Uh,
I don't know either.
I mean that was like the whole thing.
It's like the native American casinos
they were allowed to have because he
knows some places that you can never
have casinos.
Right.
Because they had their own rules.
That's where a lot of other early mma
fights were done because it was illegal.
It was illegal to have mma.
So it was illegal have mma competitions,
but it was legal to have them at the
native American places.
So they must have different malls in
some ways.
Yeah.
That's how they have casinos.
So what do you guys do and now you're
just touring across the country with
this new music?
Yeah.
They were just on tour playing some
shows when you hear for Coachella.
Yeah.
What is that experience like?
You know,
it's,
it's like most kind of festivals.
It's it,
it can be fun if you're,
if you're into that type of thing.
I guess.
I don't know.
Well,
it seems like it's got to be good for
like the young up and coming guys and
gals to be included in these lineups and
people to be able to experience maybe
some bands.
I know for honey,
honey,
it was a big deal to be able to
experience some bands that maybe you
weren't aware of before and say,
Oh,
let me.
Yeah.
For me it's kind of weird like watching
music in the sun.
It just feels weird to me.
And then.
And you don't,
you don't get sound check,
you know,
so you.
So you kind of go up there blind and
then all you know,
and then you have a very short set.
Normally most bands played,
you know,
a band is playing like the more theaters
on this plane,
like our half,
at least when you played a festival,
you have 45 minutes.
That's it,
you know.
So it's like,
you know,
it's a very,
it's a lot of effort to not be at your
best.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's sort of,
um,
that,
that can be a little difficult,
but when you play a great festival and
you get a great crowd,
it can change your mind.
I guess we just played last week and it
was awesome.
We had a really nice crowd.
It was great.
What is it like being there?
I mean,
how many people go to that God damn
thing.
It's got to be enormous now.
Yeah,
I mean it's huge.
I mean,
yeah,
it,
it's become this whole big thing out
there too.
They do two weekends now.
Yeah.
That one.
And then the weekend after that they do
essentially the same thing.
But with country music,
what's it called?
Stagecoach.
Stagecoach,
festival.
Ge.
So it was like three week.
The whole town,
like is,
is for three weeks at least,
is just completely inundated with
people.
How strange and how do they choose that
spot?
Uh,
I don't know.
They do it on the polo grounds there.
Do they use those polo grounds when it's
not in season?
Yeah.
I don't even know.
I don't know.
They just decided to put it on down
there,
but it's become this gigantic thing that
everybody has to go.
A lot of guys who do those festivals
will be the same ones who do festivals
all over the place,
you know,
they'll,
like those Lollapalooza guys to
different festivals.
They've started different ones.
And the benefit of doing those things is
really essentially just first exposure.
Right.
I mean,
there's money in it,
but it's not like you guys doing on your
own.
It's good.
Money is good.
Money.
It's better money than,
than playing shows.
You get more money.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
It's good money.
So it's nice to route a tour around
festivals.
No Shit.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's interesting,
Huh?
Because comedians always think of it as
like south by southwest has,
is when you think about festivals
festival and what is that?
That's a more an industry thing and
it's,
it's everybody's kind of playing for
free.
Yeah.
What the fuck is ours?
That's really weird when you're starting
that,
you know,
it's a place to be seen.
Yeah.
It's more for up and comers I think,
or when you have a brand new record
coming out,
you can go down there and you know that
all the media is going to be there.
Is Coachella the big festival?
I think so,
yeah.
Coachella is one of the biggest.
Lollapalooza is the other.
Yeah,
there.
There.
There are a few that are our mainstays
now.
Coachella is definitely one of them.
Do you find that in the age of the
Internet that you are getting better
crowds in different places,
that you're getting people that
understand what you're doing and are big
fans and they're.
They're all over the place now instead
of like in an urban pockets.
I don't know.
We don't go outside of urban pockets
really be honest.
Really.
I mean we stay in major cities.
We don't.
We don't often hit the small towns.
No,
because we can hit major markets in
Australia,
western Europe,
North America.
We can do it in South America and then
like by the time we finished that you
can kind of do those again.
It's like a.
You really have to want to go there and
make a lot less money.
I get it.
Makes Sense.
Yeah.
Why would you think that maybe that
would,
especially for fucking around and
creating new stuff sometimes getting a
new look,
you know,
and then being in a new place and
performing for a new counterpart,
it gives you a new feel for what you're
doing.
Yeah,
I mean I think if,
if you're,
if you're that kind of band that does a
lot of improvising and fly by the seat
of your pants,
but for me,
I'd rather be creating in the studio.
Do you enjoy travel?
Do you enjoy like international gigs?
Uh,
less and less.
Yeah.
Less and less.
The more,
the more productive I am at home,
the less I want to leave,
you know?
And I love being around my kids.
It's been a lot of fun.
So it's definitely become less and less
a thing I want to do.
I got to tell you,
dude,
you're your dedication and the way you
described wanting to do music,
it's very infectious.
I love hearing shit like this because it
really does make me want to go do
something,
you know?
I think that that effect is one of the
reasons why people really enjoy
conversations with people like you
because when we're remodeling done,
I've never done this really.
I've never really done an interview like
this.
No Shit.
Never.
He's so comfortable though.
Hi.
So comfortable.
I don't know.
I guess just,
I just feel comfortable around you.
You definitely say I feel like you're
going to keep me safe.
I 100 percent of my stock here with the
map things.
Barges didn't the door.
Everything's fine.
You're going to be fine,
but it's like when a person hears
someone like you that is just in love
with what they do and produces amazing
stuff and just has a passionate about
it,
it makes it.
There's like a bubbly thing.
It starts boiling inside it.
You want to,
you want to get going.
You want to get moving,
man.
That is the fuel of inspiration.
It's so important for people.
I mean,
I think for all of us,
um,
I think everybody who was in the certain
artists growing up knows that music
especially,
I think it's probably one of the most
inspirational things as far as like the
way it hits you,
the way emotionally way it hits you.
Like as far as art forms.
You can listen to a three minute song
and it can hit you in a way that three
minutes in a movie has no hope of like
in,
like from start to go to three first
minutes of a movie never hit you like
some songs do.
They just tell a story and this intense
moving way with music and sound and,
and the,
the soul behind the way a person sings
the words and that to hear from a guy
like you,
that that process is so intoxicating and
you love it so much and that you still
after all these years do it and love it
and can't wait to get back in there and
you want to be productive and that you
work all the time and that you work at
it.
You don't even consider it.
That's like,
that's what everybody wants to hear,
man,
because that when you hear a guy like
you talk about that,
I guarantee you this,
this podcast to be heard by over a
million people and out of those million
people,
thousands of them are going to start new
projects and get inspired to do things
just by hearing you do this.
I think it's going to fuck him,
man.
They gonna want some of that man.
So people what they hear that and they
go,
that sounds like bliss.
That sounds like career bliss.
Someone who loves what they do and for
two years
the business side is hard.
There's a lot of bullshit.
You know what I mean?
And most people don't make it.
You know,
we started over 10 years ago and we used
to tour with a bunch of bands that just
don't even exist anymore.
You know what I mean?
We've,
we know that we're lucky,
you know what I mean?
But at the same time,
I've always felt something more from
music.
You know,
it's always meant more to me than it did
to all my friends just because I don't
know why,
you know,
it's like part of my family,
but even still,
you know,
my dad had a great record collection but
I am pretty quickly like surpassed his
knowledge and just delve deeper,
you know what I mean?
But I always felt really in tune with
music.
Like I,
I can remember being like 14 and hearing
Sam Cooke and the soul stirrers and like
it making me cry,
you know what I mean?
It was able to reach some place inside
me that,
that nothing else ever was able to,
you know,
I don't know that everybody gets that
thing right.
But I definitely have that and it's like
it's really controlled the way that I've
made all the decisions for my life.
Well,
I've got to think as a young man in such
a music rich environment that you
described your childhood growing up like
that.
I mean that had to have sparked and
fueled some,
some areas of your creativity that just
led you to embrace it the way you have.
I mean,
it's,
it seems like a really fortunate
situation that you grew up in.
Yeah,
absolutely.
With that story of you guys around your
grandmother's grave singing that song,
that's an amazing story matter.
Yeah.
I kind of wish I had that in my family,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
and I,
and I know it,
I know it,
you know,
and not only were my uncle's a great
musicians,
but they think great tastes like
Michael.
Jim taught me how to sing.
He's still got one of the best voices
I've ever heard in my life,
you know what I mean?
And uh,
you know,
I was uh,
I was in a blues music,
but I was a real snob about it.
I liked certain things and I really
didn't like other things,
you know what I mean?
And I had my uncle Tim,
he just had an amazing blues albums and
he hit me to the cool shit,
you know what I mean early on.
And I knew the difference between like a
Kinda corny barb blue shit and like the
deep stuff,
you know?
And so I really had a headstart.
I can't,
I can't say that it was assault,
like I just got it,
you know,
I like,
I had great teachers and I was around
some,
some cool stuff growing up.
Yeah,
that's what it seems like,
you know,
and I think that have it being around a
bunch of people that are not,
are not just have great taste,
but also express themselves like freely
and openly like that they can sing at a,
at a funeral.
No,
that's not a lot of families where there
is so musical that they'll,
they'll sit around and sing your
grandmother's favorite song when she
died.
Well,
yeah,
I mean it,
it became,
it,
it ceased to be music.
For me it was just who I was.
It was,
it was my life as a human is music.
It's just,
it's like eating music,
showering.
I mean it's like a part of thing.
I do.
You know what I mean?
And without thinking about it and no
matter what you did,
even if you didn't pursue it as a
career,
you would still be involved in theater,
but you can.
I think so,
yeah.
I don't.
I wouldn't know,
I don't really.
I knew that I felt totally out of place,
like working in a kitchen and like
working anywhere else.
Is that a boxing glove or on your neck?
Yeah.
What's that from?
That's,
you know,
they used to give these out to golden
glove winters.
Local regional golden glove.
What did you win?
A golden gloves.
None and I,
I found it in a junk shop.
It does look cool.
I like how you're rocking it underneath
the collar.
Old School style.
Catholic school.
Like an Italian horn I suppose where I
can remember Italian horns.
No.
People used to wear those stupid little
gold horns like a horn,
like a,
like a bull horn.
That was like,
Hey,
do you know what I'm talking about?
Not at all.
It's this thing.
They would call them Italian horns.
There were a big east coast.
Guido,
where'd you grow?
That's what they look like.
A,
I was born in New Jersey and I grew up
in Boston.
That kind of looks like sperm.
Stupid charm.
It does the greatest farm.
That's probably what it really is.
Gold sperm.
There you fuck with the bull?
You get the horns.
I don't,
I don't know why it was a horn.
I have no idea what it meant,
but when I was explaining you have sperm
in your chest,
like sperm,
like liberace came in your chest.
I don't know why I brought that up.
I don't even know where they came from.
I was just curious about.
I just wanted to know if you boxed.
Yeah,
yeah.
Blocks do you.
What do you do?
Do you do it for like just for fun?
For Fun?
For,
for working out.
Do you spar or do you hit a little bit.
When my cousins in town,
he taught me how to box.
He has been boxing since he was 14.
He got me into it three or four years
ago.
I have some friends who still spar and
I'm like,
dude,
be careful.
Yeah.
Even though you had those things,
the big helmets on it,
shit hurts.
Those helmets don't really help.
You know the,
the,
the problem is the brain smushing around
inside the head and those helmets.
Nobody's hitting me like that.
No,
no,
but just a little jolt.
Even jolts like that real bad for the
brain sloshing around inside the head.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I was talking to a doctor.
He said that jet skiing can give you
brain damage.
Jet Skiing,
jet skiing,
just being on a jet ski.
He said the bounce of a jet ski,
no bullshit.
Gives people concussions.
Wow.
Yeah.
He goes,
you don't realize what a concussion is
is you're concussed.
Like the impact doesn't have to hit you
in the head.
You get a lot of concussions have from
people getting hit in the chest and then
all of a sudden there'll be depressed
and their mood swings be.
Their cortisol levels are all fucked up.
They'll find out that there's from the,
from the sort of like whiplash from the
movement of the impact.
Yeah,
I always heard that.
Yeah.
That's what I am and I know it's true in
boxing gloves.
I know they cause more brain damage than
the small gloves.
I know MMA is technically safer than
boxing is in the longterm.
Yeah.
Believe it or not,
I'd actually be safer if they weren't.
No gloves.
Yeah,
absolutely.
No gloves,
no risk tape.
You,
your,
your wrist would band easier,
it'd be harder to hit people hard and
also your hands would break because he'd
have to pick your shots better.
Absolutely.
Safety,
safety first.
Safety first.
Even in extreme sports.
Well that's the thing,
right?
Like how safe can you make it while
still have it be so exciting?
I don't know.
Right.
Do you watch boxing now though?
You follow?
Yeah.
You're a big boxing fan.
Oh yeah.
Chocolate Tito's does in this Santa
Monica right now.
Training.
Have you watched him?
Uh,
I mean I'm a big fan of his.
I've never seen him live,
but I want to go there and watch them
train.
Yeah,
man,
I watched Manny Pacquiao.
Train was,
it was a real pleasure.
It was um,
I went and trained at wildcard and they
let me go down and train in the room.
The manny room.
Oh yeah.
And you know,
the double end bag was like so fucking
tight.
Yeah.
I could barely hit the thing.
I felt so stupid because I was like,
alright,
I'm at a place where I feel comfortable.
I can go to wildcard and maybe work out
and not feel like a total shit had and I
was like,
I gotta get Outta here.
I was like,
give me a couple of wildcard t shirts.
You never see me again.
Watching manny hit the pads.
A man who was hitting the pads wasn't
with him.
Was it with Freddie Roach?
It might've been with Freddy.
Yeah,
it was with Freddy,
Freddy and another guy.
Um,
and he goes through all this warm up
routines and goes through all this stuff
and then he starts hitting the pads
kinda slow and loosens up and then
eventually he starts firing off these
combinations.
My mom
and he's just firing off these ungodly
quick combinations and you just realize
like,
yeah,
there's a difference.
There's a difference in certain people.
Yeah.
There's a big difference.
See Calves?
Yeah.
You said what the hell is going on over
there?
Well,
that's where his power comes from.
Ms Dot Perez,
all from his legs.
The pushing off of the legs and
delivering these lightening fast
combinations.
Yeah.
Did you see his last fight was an
absolute bust?
They lost money.
Yeah,
nobody wants to see him fight if it's
not floyd mayweather and people were
really disappointed to.
Well,
that's not totally true.
I mean,
he just fought Tim Bradley.
We've this just like third fight.
I don't think anybody really cared to.
Bradley's a fun guy.
Tim Bradley's awesome.
It's this third fight.
Let's.
But it was interesting to have great
welterweights out there.
I agree.
Terence Crawford the best.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
I want,
I don't want to see that.
He just,
he's,
he's just inked a deal with the fight.
Victor postle.
Oh really?
It's going to be a great fight too.
I think a terrence was going to win it,
but that's a.
that's a really good fight and I'd love
to see the terrence Crawford isn't
scared to,
to fight anybody that even the best
terrence is something special and also
that he,
he fights from the Orthodox stance but
just as good if not better for the south
southpaw and they'll switch up on guys.
He'll like,
I hate when I see guys do that.
I'm like,
oh,
this fucking guy.
But he's awesome.
It's almost like he's feeling you out as
an Orthodox and then when he knows he
can fuck you up,
he switches over and start to lighten
you up.
[inaudible] he's something special.
He's awesome and I love to watch.
Is his brain work to cause?
He does.
He.
He won't just go out for the knockout or
whatever.
He's.
He plays with.
He plays with it for a few rounds while
smart.
Gently.
Yes.
He always plays with the person for a
few rounds and then starts destroying
them.
Well,
I think he values and appreciates the
skill and art of boxing,
the actual art of it.
I mean there's no way he can be as good
as he is.
If you get to that level,
you have to.
You have to reach that point where you
understand that it's a total art to it.
Yeah.
So what he's doing is he's setting traps
and slowly dragging guys into his game
and then fucking them up.
Yeah.
And for a guy who really appreciates
that,
the skill and the subtleties of,
of what he's doing,
it's amazing.
Absolutely.
I love watching that guy said traps
chocolates.
He does.
Awesome too,
because he's just watching his side to
side movement while.
Yeah,
watching.
It's just like second nature for him.
Yeah.
More more so than anybody.
[inaudible] he's just a boxer.
Know the fluidity of those combinations
would step off to the left and crank off
these Lopez in that way where it's just
like perfect form and the movement is
insane.
This is a good time for boxing right
now.
Gennady Golovkin and another one.
I want to see what happens with Canelo
Alvarez and I'm gon Ca Amir Khan,
which is coming up.
I worry about con,
you know,
we're talking about muscles and con
keeps saying I feel stronger and he
looks huge.
It looks ripped.
I worry that he just will have no
stamina in the fight.
Yeah.
I wonder,
um,
is this the first time,
what are they finding at one 60,
1:54
member.
So when mayweather and him fought,
they fought at 1:50.
Was it a catch weight fight?
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
You want me whether I wanted them a
little small,
right.
Maybe with they get you ever drank them
down a little bit.
Get that big bruiser down,
but a Gennady Golovkin is a,
he's an interesting guy because a lot of
people don't want to,
like his paper view got 150,000
buys,
which is a huge bust.
It's a disaster for them.
But for boxing fans like you or me or
like best,
he's the guy to walk.
Can't wait to watch it.
We still haven't seen him tested though.
I don't think.
I don't think so either.
But he's going to fight,
you know,
everybody wants to see him fight.
Wade.
I mean,
I'm Canelo for sure,
but it's fighting.
Who is he?
Uh,
yeah.
It's Wade.
Wade is the guy's name.
The mandatory challenge.
Always fighting weight right now.
But Andre Ward.
Oh,
it's going to go up and fight Cova love
though.
You know that Andrea was now fighting
75.
He had his first light heavyweight fight
at 75.
Look Great.
And now he's going to fight Koval.
Koval lives a beast.
Oh,
he's another terrifying guy.
Yeah,
it's a great time.
Bernard Hopkins,
uh,
you know,
as old as he is and kind of as slowly as
he is with respect.
He popped a few times.
He did.
I mean,
it was the Bernard Hopkins have 10 years
ago.
It could have been completely different.
Fun.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Like I think if,
uh,
again it's,
it's,
that's the other thing about boxing is
like with the thing that's so great
about mma is they pick the best against
the best.
And in boxing there's so much bullshit.
You know,
you got to see these dumb fucking fights
with guys fighting people that,
you know,
they can just be so easily.
Definitely too many different world
titles.
Like you have three different guys are
called themselves the world champion and
they're in the same weight class.
That's crazy.
You know,
there's a lot of that.
That doesn't make any sense.
Like,
yeah,
deciding what a world champion is and
who owns the right to say world champion
that their guy is or this guy is and not
have them fight against each other.
Rival promotions.
They don't want to get together and make
deals that don't wanna lose our
superstar.
What if,
what if the USC had a company that was
just as big as USC because that's kind
of essentially what happens in boxing,
you know what I mean?
You don't,
you don't talk about it and use it
because there's no one else really can
compete,
you know,
if you want to do mma,
you do them.
You guys see,
right.
You know,
Bell Torch is not quite as big,
but like with boxing,
there are just all these promoters,
top ranking and Aram and that they never
crossed promote.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
it,
it really does a disservice to the
sport.
I think.
Oh,
it certainly can because they know that
they,
they have a guy who can make a lot of
money and if that guy loses to somebody,
then they're fucked and they lose their
big guy.
And that's the other thing I kind of
hate about boxing is that if you lose
one fight,
somehow you're tainted beyond belief.
Do you know what I mean?
I don't quite understand that.
Yeah.
Well,
it's an old school way of thinking
because they used to build a fighter up
and get them 49 and oh,
and then they would fight,
you know?
Right.
And it would be a big thing.
He's undefeated.
He's going for the title.
You know,
if a guy had 10 losses and he was gone
for the title,
everybody will like,
why am I even watching this?
That's why it's so cool to see con fight
Canelo and to see,
uh,
you know,
to see who did we just say Miguel cotto
who's another post dol laws?
Zoning.
Postal.
Oh,
Gennady Golovkin.
No postal.
Terrence Crawford is calling me.
It's so great when you actually see a
real fight.
It's like,
Oh shit,
this is awesome.
Yeah.
Well,
there's just too much talent right now
in a few divisions.
Like it's,
there's some unavoidable like chaotic
matchups and I think Canelo and Amir
Khan for as long as it lasts,
she'd be very interesting.
Canal is just such a bruiser man.
He's a scary puncher,
but he's slow.
He's a little slow and pretty fast when
you see him against mayweather.
When he fought mayweather,
he couldn't even catch him.
Yeah,
that's true.
But maybe whether it's a mother fucker,
he's such a good box on is is you could
argue is as fast maybe.
Well he won't be losing as much weight
so maybe he'll be better and maybe we'd
be better because he fought that fight,
you know?
I mean a fighter doesn't stay at the
same level of skill year after year.
Ideally if they keep training and keep
learning and he's completely dedicated,
he's going to be getting better and
better all the time.
Confident as champion.
You mean that one lost to mayweather?
I think you probably learned more about
what can happen to him in a fight.
Then all those fights were beat guys
down.
Yeah.
I don't.
I,
I can't imagine the pressure that
Canelo's under.
I want to see Canelo and Gennady.
Golovkin.
That's the fight that I want to say.
Yeah.
I want to see what happens.
That's this two guys that don't like to
take backward steps.
Both have ruthless power and great
Chen's.
Yeah.
I think he's a better boxer.
He's so technical.
I love watching him train to video him
training,
just like just working the head movement
in the clinch for like an hour,
you know what I mean?
Just like.
And then he's like teaching some kid
also stopped to teach somebody.
It's like he loves the sport.
You can tell.
Yeah,
he certainly does,
but I think Canelo does too.
I think Canelo is,
like you said,
is a little slower and he's just such a
bruiser that he's got that sort of style
to them that he just loads up and bangs
it guys,
but I think he's getting better too.
I think he's slicker now that he's ever
been before.
I think also a fight like mayweather,
just such a wake up call and you could
fight a guy like me with her or hate
him.
He's arguably one of the greatest boxers
ever.
The guy retires and I know they're
tired.
It's not an argument.
No argument.
Yeah.
He's one of the greatest,
if not the greatest.
I mean he has this uncanny ability.
He has the uncanny ability to make every
fight.
He fights the most boring fight you've
ever seen your life.
Incredible,
and it,
you know,
it kinda sucks because it's hard to get
your friends into boxing when it's like
check it out.
This is supposed to be the best fight of
the Millennium Pacquiao versus
mayweather and it's everybody's like,
what the fuck can we want something
else?
You know what?
He just fights so safe and so smart and
he's better.
He's better at fighting that style.
Then you are dealing with that style and
so when guys fight them,
they just can't get to them and they
fall into this sort of defensive shell
like eight or nine rounds in where they
ended up making it look foolish.
Yeah.
You start with swinging wildly and like
you play right into this trap.
Yeah.
It's almost,
it almost sucks that I want to know
who's going to fight next.
You think he's gonna fight again?
Yeah.
Really?
I don't think at one point in time you
don't think he's going to retire.
Maybe.
I haven't heard any real rumbling.
So have you.
He just started flamboyantly saying he
was retiring too much for me to believe
it's a real retirement.
It just feels like more of his
promotion,
you know what I mean?
And it's not like a stop training.
He hasn't.
I don't think so.
No.
He's in the gym still.
Well you're probably right.
Then maybe he was waiting for the manny
Pacquiao fight,
like maybe waiting to see if it
generated a lot of income and if manny
was back and people loved them because
you got to kind of give manny a chance
to rebound like after the one man,
Walmart as fight we get knocked out.
He had to give him a chance to take some
time off.
Fight Against Chris Algieri look good.
And then you could mark the fight.
Yeah.
I don't know that,
that was just such a bust for me,
that fight.
It was just so,
so goddamn boring,
you know,
and I,
I was such a manny Pacquiao fan and to
see him,
to see him come up with nothing and then
have it,
have the shoulder thing afterwards,
after the fact got it sucked.
While the word was before the fight that
the shoulder was fucked up.
Yeah.
People had heard about that.
It was bookies were talking about it.
So some people didn't know that her
shoulder was fucked up.
Yeah,
they should've.
They should've postpone the fight.
Yeah.
But the problem is that in the,
like some association sue them or
something like that.
Well,
I mean he threw punches with it.
I mean there was a class action lawsuit.
So the question is,
was was it the injury bad back?
But I don't know what he did for a shop.
Cortisone shot before the fight.
And they said no.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I should've just done it.
Can't ask shit like that.
Just do it.
Get a bunch of buddies to do it.
I mean I just love them and pack.
He's like mini Elvis flying around his
own jumbo jet with like a jumbo jet full
of his entourage.
Yeah,
he's got a,
he's got a whole whole giant posy and
none of them like gay people.
That was such a bummer.
It was weird.
Yeah.
But that's all that religious stuff
though,
man.
It's just heavy Catholic.
Yeah.
But Catholic or not,
you hate to see somebody who's so
fucking blessed.
A tear people down and over.
Nothing,
I mean,
I,
I'd never paid for a manny Pacquiao
fight again because of that.
Yeah.
Really?
Wow.
Fuck that.
That's interesting.
One hundred percent.
When you get to that level and you have
that much money,
you should know fucking better.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
That's disgusting what he said.
And then he said it twice.
Yeah.
We tried to justify with the Bible God's
word.
Well,
I mean,
he probably didn't know the reaction
that he was going to get,
you know,
I bet in his culture he said gays are
less than dogs,
less than animals.
Was that the exact word?
Yeah.
Um,
I think he might've been misquoted,
I think.
I think they tried to explain what he
said based on what it says in the Bible
that aisle after the fact.
Yeah.
I don't remember,
but yeah,
whatever it was was not good.
I don't know,
man.
It just,
it's just he's too rich and too too
blessed to be bringing people down,
persecute people down.
There's just no good.
I took costume,
a lot of fucking money,
man.
He lost his nike sponsorship because
I'll never get my $99.
Ninety five,
that's for sure.
Yeah.
You're not the only one.
I'm sure it is a farmer.
I don't know that that many boxing fans
who actually care.
You don't think so.
I don't know.
There's gotta be some boxing fans like
you that are boxing fans,
but our apes maybe for sure.
Yeah.
All those people watching or.
No,
I mean my friends,
my friend bought,
bought the last fight and I kinda gave
him a little shit and he just.
Because of the gay stuff.
Yeah,
you do that,
you know it's going to be shitty blood
anyway.
It's like,
why would you.
Well,
the poor guy,
he's all ate up with Jesus.
Yeah.
I just,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I'm not that familiar with his culture
and exactly how,
but I know for a fact a lot of
Catholics.
Yeah.
All the Philippines is just overwhelmed
with Christianity and Catholicism,
so he probably thought he was actually
trying to save people some strange way,
you know,
in his brainwashed mind.
Yeah.
I wonder how much of the negative
feedback actually gets to him though,
you know,
none.
You don't think so?
No.
You don't think I'm saying it's like
mini Elvis.
He doesn't hear anything.
He's got shades on.
50 people and his own jumbo jet.
Who's going to tell him that he's an
asshole?
I want to know.
But money can last if he keeps rolling
in the Philippines.
Yeah.
Well honestly you'd probably say his
money with his own check because they
need to have to buy 50 plane tickets.
Cab,
right.
If it's cost effective for him to have
his own jet,
that's an interesting way to look at.
But he's so beloved in this country.
They probably just give him a jet.
You know,
he just held representative country.
That guy's a hell of a pool player.
He.
Yeah.
And he's a lefty too.
He plays really good.
He plays like at a professional level.
Does he?
Yeah.
Well the Philippines or it's a giant
place for pool.
Uh,
the Gis brought it over there in the
fifties and uh,
some of the best pool players in the
world to come out of the Philippines,
matter of fact,
the consensus,
greatest player of all time,
effort,
and Reyes came out of the Philippines.
A logician yeah.
Yeah.
They have some of the best players and
really interesting to watch them because
they play like they're playing a musical
instrument,
like a very gentle game for them.
It's very different.
It's not like stiff or hard.
It's a very gentle flowing.
Yeah.
Their stroke,
they have a very particular type of
stroke that other players worldwide have
emulated the Filipino style of play
pool.
Wow.
Interesting.
I didn't know that.
You
know,
what,
what other countries are like embracing
American rock and Blues Music and doing
a good job with it today.
I mean,
UK is always been a huge supporter.
France,
Australia,
they've always,
you know,
Australia,
I mean,
shit,
they live in live and die for rock and
roll.
Do they get good artists that are coming
out of there today?
Like do you,
what do you,
where do you see?
Yeah.
Uh,
Australia,
there's,
there's great,
great music coming out of there and
maybe do you ever listened to tame
impala?
No,
they're from,
they're from Australia.
How do you spell it?
T ime and then impala.
Tame Impala.
They make really cool records.
They're pretty famous now.
I,
I would say they,
they might even be like a festival
headliner at this point.
Really the other big band and uh,
and they're from Australia.
There's a whole scene.
They're kind of around that in the
absence of radio,
like what is the traditional method that
bands get noticed now?
Like is it just hustling and Torrin and
spread?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
You just do your shit.
I have no fucking idea.
I just had an 85 year old gospel singer
from Mississippi and my studio last week
and that's all I was thinking about.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
wow,
I have no idea with what goes on in the
music business.
I really don't.
What was the gospel singers name?
His name is Leo.
Bud Welch.
Wow.
Oh yeah.
So cool.
What'd you have to do?
Play music man.
But what,
like what we did a record with them,
uh,
I had some,
some of my friends in and we,
uh,
we just sorta like would let him start a
song and try to try to,
you know,
get him where he fit in.
Wow.
Yeah.
And we did a whole record in three days
with them and then,
you know,
it's just like,
that's incredible.
Yeah.
He was,
he's incredible.
He plays guitar and sings and he's very
frail and kind of hunched over.
But he keeps perfect time.
Like we could record them by himself and
then you could just watch him on a,
like with the bpm hedges right on it,
man.
That's wild.
A lifetime of doing it.
You know,
there's something about Old Gospel and
old blues.
There's like a,
there's,
there's a sound to like a lot of the old
south that uh,
the inescapable soulful sound.
You know,
there's some,
there's some old blues like to this day,
like some John Lee Hooker,
like boom,
boom,
boom.
Like you listen to like wow,
like this is just such a special kind of
sound and it's instantaneous and you
don't have to know anything about it to
love it.
Yeah.
Which is so cool.
And it took the world by storm.
I mean John Lee Hooker was really
influential in Africa.
Like his record.
He went over there and people like Ali
Farka Toure.
He was like one of the greatest African
guitar players heard his records and
inspired him.
You know?
I mean,
yeah,
it's just that there's something about
it that's like some of those guys.
It's just undeniably awesome and you
don't really know how to describe it.
There's like the ingredients are so
minimal.
Yeah.
Everybody else had a guitar.
Why didn't they make it sound like that
too?
You know what I mean?
Well,
it seems like there was a bunch of
different things going on.
It was the,
the audience that had been exposed to a
lot of other great music and they
appreciated it.
There was like the experience of the
people that were performing it,
the life experience that they had behind
the words they had lived like sorrowful
times and expressed it legitimately and,
and,
and truly in the music.
Right.
But it was also just where they're from.
Who they.
Yeah.
So that's who they are.
It's not even like that there maybe
their lives were so bad.
It's just like,
again,
it's like it's just such a part of who
they were.
They,
they would never be able to explain it.
Right.
You know what I mean?
And they could never teach a course on
blues and a,
at Harvard,
you know,
you have to live it right.
And you'd have to experience that vibe
from another musician to know that it's
possible for someone to do it.
Right.
I don't know.
I mean,
I,
there's only so much you can learn from
people.
You know,
at a certain point you have to
understand that what makes them special
is because it's stem,
it comes out of them.
You can't learn that.
You can't really take it,
but what you can take is the feeling of
they had their own identity and you've
got to find that in yourself.
That's the thing that you want to
ultimately get,
you know what I mean?
You want to be influenced by all these
people.
But the main influence that I think you
should learn from the greats are that
you,
you have to find it in yourself.
You know,
you can't rely on anybody else.
Right.
And I think to see it in someone else
gives you that inspiration to try to
find it in yourself.
So I used to search for it.
Just constant.
I mean it'd be at the library,
getting up vhs,
you know,
videos and just watching,
rewinding,
watching,
and then I would drive 19 hours from
Akron to Mississippi just to like maybe
find a musician who I heard lived in
some town,
you know what I mean?
Just because I wanted to see it and
know.
And,
and when I find,
when I found it,
shit is life changing man.
I mean,
I was like 17 and I went to Greenville,
Mississippi and I just started asking
around for this musician named,
his name was t model Ford and he made
some really cool t model Ford.
Yeah.
He was a total bad ass.
He played a death metal guitar.
Like really the PV.
Yeah.
And it said with the letters you put on
a mailbox,
it's like said t model Ford.
The tail dragger had it spray painted on
his trailer that he pulled her out with
his Lincoln and I just go in there.
I would never want to just like become
that person.
Right.
But whether they're from Mississippi or
they're like a classical composer from
Germany,
there's a thing that these all these
guys have in common and it's like a
sense of self,
you know what I mean?
Anybody I've ever met has a real.
Just a confidence that,
you know,
even though they may not be the best at
certain things,
they can like bring out the best in
themselves,
you know,
and that.
And that's like enough.
Do you know what I mean?
I definitely know what you mean.
I know what you mean.
Yeah,
I know exactly what you mean.
You described it very well.
That's a great way of putting it.
Is it like to seeing it and other people
recognizing it in other people and
trying to find it in yourself and that.
So seeing it in other people me and know
that it's real thing that inspires.
Yes,
absolutely.
Yes.
And you see somebody like t model or any
of those guys,
you know,
they didn't have any extra thing.
They didn't have anything like any like
advantage really.
Do you know what I mean?
It was a struggle just like it is for
anybody,
you know,
but they found it in themselves I guess.
Well that's all.
Any artists you'd ever hope for them.
That's the number one aspiration.
Find out whatever is the best part of
you.
Right.
How do you get your best stuff out
there?
I mean,
I'm still trying.
Well,
you know,
I mean I think that uh,
I,
for me,
I just don't want ever be too critical.
Self critical.
I want it to be.
I want to try to like have it on,
on the record,
like in it for the first couple takes.
So it feels for me,
I'll feel a little bit more real,
a bit more genuine.
Do you know what I mean?
I think that was really helpful to a
record.
Some of my favorite records,
whether they're hip hop or whether the
rock and roll or whatever.
There may generally made pretty quickly
big grand master pieces that were
labored over.
I don't tend to listen to that much.
I'll listen to it and it'll be.
Maybe I'll hear something sonically that
little.
That's cool that they did that.
But then like at the end of the day,
I always go and put on that one record
that that one guy did in a day.
You know,
that's the one I always want to live
with.
That's my desert island shit,
you know,
my desert island.
Shit.
Well listen man,
thank you very much for doing this.
I really appreciate you coming in here.
And um,
I,
I appreciate what you do too.
I really do.
And so for me,
I'm geeked out fan.
I'm super psyched and to get you to talk
about your creative process like that,
it's just giant for me.
So if people want to get your music,
the Arcs,
you guys,
uh,
what do you,
what do you have out that's out right
now?
We have a record called years dreamily
and that's,
uh,
available at all of the,
all the
correct jobs that don't exist anymore.
Itunes.
All everywhere.
Yeah.
Everywhere.
Beautiful.
All right.
Thanks brother.
Appreciate you being here,
man.
Thank you.
That's it for the week.
Fuckers.
See next week.
Thanks everybody.
Bye.
The.